so today is just a big day for Avengers
for updates today I did a video on some
sources confirming that Avengers
annihilation will in fact be the title
for Avengers 4 and now thanks to some
sources as well we have an update on the
trailer I'm still giving away copies of
infinity war and ant-man and the wasp on
blu-ray as well as some special edition
posters if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero so as I
mentioned a few weeks ago the Avengers 4
trailer was going through digital
remastering this was great news because
it meant that the trailer is coming soon
now some people tried to say it that
this was fake because Avengers 4 is
being shot with all IMAX cameras but
that doesn't matter it still has to go
through digital remastering Avengers
infinity war it was shot the exact same
way all IMAX cameras but still went
through digital remastering and you can
find that directly on their site if you
look at a vendor's infinity war on the
IMAX website it says the IMAX release of
Avengers infinity war it will be
digitally remastered into the image and
sound quality the IMAX experience with
proprietary IMAX DMR digital remastering
technology so even though it was shot
with all IMAX cameras it still went
through digital remastering and this
previous report is actually falling more
into place now as we have more updates
so like I said a few weeks ago we talked
about it going through the process of
digital remastering well that process is
now complete the Avengers 4 trailer has
been reported to have completed its IMAX
conversion with this information comes
the report that the teaser trailer is
also being ready to be shipped out with
theatrical cartridges very soon it has
been rumored that the trailer will drop
in November and now with this report
lining up with that perfectly and some
details from international trailer
sources this morning it seems like the
trailer is confirmed to come out in
November these come from very reliable
sources one that has confirmed titles
for other trailers and movies before and
the other who confirmed the
max DMR conversion and releases for Star
Wars the last Jedi and solo a Star Wars
story so again today big news today it
seems like we have our title Avengers
annihilation
we know that the Avengers 4 trailer has
now finished its IMAX conversion and the
teaser trailer is being ready to be
shipped out with its theatrical
cartridges really soon and it appears
that the trailer will be dropping in
November everything is so close to
happening it's almost here so let me
know what you all think about this new
information and let me know how excited
you are to see the first teaser trailer
for Avengers 4 hit me with your thoughts
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe comment and like the video
so you can enter the giveaway and stay
up to date with everything related to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]